CHELSIE CZOP: Welcome.
Thanks for joining us
to review what's new
and what's next with
infrastructure for AI and ML.
I'm Chelsie Czop, Product
Manager for Compute Engine
within Google Cloud.
And I'm joined today by
Omkar Pathak, Product Manager
for Cloud TPUs within Google.
First, we'll review our
accelerator mission, AI and ML
within Google, how we're
able to provide you
with a differentiated
compute platform,
and the ways to take advantage
of our accelerator hardware.
Then we'll focus on our
accelerator hardware platform,
Cloud GPUs, and Cloud TPUs.
We'll cover what's new and
what's next in the portfolio
and sprinkle in ways
that our customers
are creating innovative products
and services within Google
Cloud.
At Google Cloud, we believe that
cutting-edge machine learning
infrastructure should excel
at performance, scalability,
and usability to allow
you to be able to create
innovative and differentiated
services for your users,
all at a low total
cost of ownership.
Our leadership in AI through
both Google research, DeepMind,
and also in the practical
applications of AI
within our Google
products, allow
us to be able to provide you
with an innovative platform
for your AI and ML use cases.
We bring our experience
of deploying AI and ML
models in production
across all of Google
and provide you with the
same infrastructure and tools
that we use.
This means we have accelerators
for any of your use cases,
from high-performance
training to serving models
cost-effectively.
You're able to achieve the
optimal price per performance
for your use case through our
selection of Cloud GPUs, Cloud
TPUs, as well as
compute-optimized VMs
on Compute Engine.
This gives you the
ability to choose
the latest and
greatest infrastructure
to fit your use case needs.
Last, and arguably
most important for you,
is that it's easy to
get started and to scale
using a wide range
of tools and services
offered through Compute
Engine and Vertex AI platform,
allowing you to create
business value faster.
It really helps to partner
with companies that have fully
deployed AI and ML in their
own production environments
to help you overcome
roadblocks faster.
We have a long history
of hardware development.
And we're always dedicated
to being an open cloud,
allowing you a
diversity of options,
from frameworks to
application portability.
We're at a really exciting time
in the world for AI and ML.
Every industry will
soon be transformed.
The organizations that
embrace the AI and ML
in this transformation will
have a competitive advantage.
To unlock the full
value of AI and ML,
we must first focus on
your business challenges.
We're able to do that
in two progressive ways.
First, you can focus on
common business challenges.
Shown here are the common
business challenges
by industry, along with the
solutions that we've created
to help you easily get started.
Then, moving on, you're able
to solve challenges that
are unique to your business.
The following solutions,
services, APIs, and models
all help with AI needs
at every single level
of expertise and readiness.
You.
Really don't need to be an
ML expert to get started.
We have easy-to-use
APIs or AutoML models
that allow you to
create a customized
solution to your unique
business challenges.
You can plug and play
the APIs and models
to create exactly what you need.
Underneath this entire portfolio
are our hardware accelerators,
Cloud TPUs, Cloud GPUs,
and Compute Engine.
There's three main ways to
take advantage of accelerators
on Google Cloud.
First we have Vertex AI,
offering end-to-end AI
and ML tooling and
scheduling via GKE
using containers, enabling
GPUs and TPUs as a service,
removing the burden from you to
manage the hardware or the VMs
for your AI workload.
Simply give your
containers access
to GPUs via the Kubernetes
API, and then you're
able to take advantage
of autoscaling,
see the GPU utilization,
and scale these workloads up
and down based on the demand.
Last, also via
Compute Engine, we
offer custom VM shapes, tooling,
and workflow support for you
to be able to scale from a
single GPU under your desk
to supercomputer computing
scale available on demand
with preemptible instances,
as well as committed
use discounts based
on reservations,
to get you the best price.
Our virtual machines
are available
in many configurations,
including predefined sizes that
align to Numa topology or,
as we've mentioned prior,
the ability to create
a custom machine type
size for your specific needs.
Then you aren't having
to manage a single VM.
You're also able to use managed
instance groups in a way
to control an entire fleet
of your infrastructure.
You're able to
define a set of VMs
and scale up and
down as you need
or as your application requires.
Now let's dive into what's
new with Cloud GPUs.
Within our Cloud
GPU portfolio, we
have an accelerator
for your use cases
from ML training and inference,
GPU-enabled HPC, CUDA Compute,
and GPU-accelerated
visualization.
Our high-end offerings include
high-performance GPUs, A100s
and B100s, that are great
for training, inference, HPC,
and CUDA Compute.
On the other end
of the spectrum,
we have T4s, which are
in more global locations,
providing you low latency
at a very low cost.
A very common use case that
we see with our customers
is training and doing
inference on A100s or B100s
and then serving in that
global capacity on T4s.
Let's take a closer look
at our A100 offering.
They're available in our
accelerator-optimized VM
family, A2s, on Compute Engine.
The A100s have 40
gigabits of memory.
And within the VM,
you can provision up
to 96 Cascade Lake vCPUs
and 1.3 terabytes of memory.
They're in fixed VM shapes to
align with the new transparent
Numa topology.
And they can scale up to 16
GPUs for scale-up and scale-out
workloads, such as natural
language processing
and computer vision.
But don't worry if
you don't need 16.
You can go all the
way down to two GPUs
to be able to
easily get started.
NVLINK fabric is the
all-to-all connectivity
with up to 9.6 terabytes
per second peak bandwidth.
You also have the access
to advanced networking
as well as the
option for local SSD.
With all these features,
you're able to achieve up
to 20 petaops of int8 all
within a single VM, which is
what I call mega performance.
As I mentioned earlier,
T4s on Google Cloud
are able to provide a low
latency at a low cost.
They're currently in 18 regions,
with more along the way.
What's new is that we do
have flexible T4s in preview
currently.
You can provision exactly
what you need for T4s
from vCPU and VM memory.
We're also launching automatic
CUD renewals, Committed Use
Discounts, for GPUs.
This helps reduce
cost and accidental
loss of your reservations.
Now, here's what's really going
to make a difference for you
for being able to easily find
capacity in your selected
region for batch workloads.
We have distribution shapes
within managed instance groups
set to Any.
The way you're able to
take advantage of this
is in three very
simple, easy steps.
First, create a
managed instance group.
Second, set the
distribution shape to Any.
And three, specify your
target audience and region.
Optionally, you can also
run preemptible GPUs VMs
to save money.
You can take note
of any constraints
that you have, such
as supported hardware
in their zones or resource
quotas, to get started.
We also have the option
for deep learning
and HPC VMs that
allows you to easily
get started on our
infrastructure within minutes.
A simple one-click
install, and your machine
is provisioned and already
performance-optimized
on Google Cloud.
It also has
compatibility-tested.
So you have no need to worry
about the software stack.
Simply select the CPU, GPU,
or TPU to add on to the VM.
We also provide the
choice and flexibility
between different ML models,
or you have the ability
to install your own.
Schrodinger's team was looking
for a cloud provider that
was just as committed
to advancing life
sciences and drug
discovery as they were.
That's why they
chose Google Cloud.
They also chose
Google because we're
known for our strength of
our network and our security
posture.
The partnership
drastically changed the way
they were doing drug discovery.
And as Dr. Farid said,
this could potentially
transform all of the way that
pharma is doing drug discovery.
As with any large
resource-intensive models,
cost does start to pile up.
The price per performance
worked really well for them
to create and discover
life-saving drugs
to help combat COVID.
If they're able to do this
cost-efficiently using
custom types of
VMs with GPUs, then
think about what you'd be
able to do with your workload.
With the change in consumer
behavior due to COVID,
Pagani was able to
create a virtual showroom
to allow you to
customize your own car
from the comfort of your couch.
This virtual showroom is served
on NVIDIA T4s with the NVIDIA
RTX virtual workstation image.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Next, let's pass it up to
Omkar to cover Cloud TPUs,
what's new, and what's next.
Take it away, Omkar.
OMKAR PATHAK: Thanks, Chelsie.
We have seen
tremendous innovation
in the field of machine
learning in the past few years.
And we expect this
rate of innovation
to grow in the future.
However, this fast-paced
innovation requests
ever-increasing amounts
of computing power.
As machine learning
models get more accurate,
they tend to get
larger, more complex,
and require larger data sets.
This is exactly why
Google built TPUs,
to accelerate the rate of
machine learning innovation
by delivering high performance
and by training and serving
at a very low cost.
TPUs are used in many
products at Google.
And it's likely that
you have interacted
with these when you have used
some of Google's products.
These accelerators are
available to you in Google Cloud
right now.
Our goal with TPUs is to
advance machine learning
at Google and across the world.
So TPUs are built for this
end-to-end user journey
of an app developer
or a researcher,
starting from fast-paced
iterative development
in the beginning all the way to
large-scale production training
and serving across a range of
machine learning use cases--
vision, language,
recommendations, and more.
It's also easy to get
started with Cloud
TPUs with TensorFlow,
PyTorch, or JAX
in the Google Cloud
project or equivalent.
You can also bring
your own models
or use one of our reference
models to get started.
What's even more
interesting is that once you
get started with
Cloud TPUs, it's
easy to scale your machine
learning models on Cloud TPU
pods, which means that
you can use petaflops
of computing power with
minimal code changes.
This image here shows
a Cloud TPU v3 pod,
which has 2,048
cores that are built
from the ground-up
for machine learning.
All of these cores
are connected together
with a custom-built, super-fast
interconnect, which is really
what delivers that
high performance when
you scale your machine learning
models on a Cloud TPU pod.
Combined with the
low cost of renting
Cloud TPUs on Google Cloud as
opposed to owning your own data
centers, this
high-performance machine
can unlock completely new
opportunities for innovation
without any upfront capital
investment on your part.
To understand the power
of easy scalability,
just look at our recent
results in MLPerf,
which is the industry standard
benchmark for ML performance.
Cloud TPUs demonstrated
leading performance numbers
across a range of machine
learning use cases.
And as you can see
in the chart here,
Cloud TPUs can train some of
the common machine learning
reference models in
just a few seconds--
for example, TLRM in 38
seconds or BERT in 17 seconds.
We believe that this
is incredibly valuable,
especially since large-scale
ML training has unlocked some
of the recent
breakthroughs in AI--
for example, lambda
in natural language
processing in multimodal models.
Cloud TPUs are particularly
well-suited for these kinds
of compute-intensive,
large-scale machine learning
workloads.
Over the last few years, we
have made relentless progress
on TPU hardware and software.
And this year, we are excited
to announce our latest
generation, Cloud TPU v4.
On a chip-to-chip
basis, Cloud TPU v4
is more than twice as fast
as its previous generation.
And at a pod scale,
Cloud TPU v4 pods
take Google Cloud's machine
learning infrastructure
to a whole new level,
with more than one exaflop
of computing power
equivalent to more than 10
million laptops combined.
We have already deployed
many of these pods
in Google's data
centers and will soon
have more, many of
which will be operating
at or near 90%
carbon-free energy.
Cloud TPU v4 pods will be
available to our Google Cloud
customers in
preview in Q4, 2021.
Now, it's not just
the sheer computing
power that pushes machine
learning innovation forward.
We believe that making
the system easy to use
is just as important as well.
And so we recently launched
a completely new software
architecture that helps you
interact much more easily
and much more seamlessly
with Cloud TPUs.
With Cloud TPU VMs, you can
now drag full Cloud TPU parts
directly from your desks
for the first time.
It's like having a machine
learning supercomputer
under your desk.
With Cloud TPU VMs, we aim to
make interactive supercomputing
attainable to our users.
And it's been incredibly
encouraging to see
positive feedback from
our early customers.
For example, Hugging Face,
which is a leading open source
provider of NLP technologies,
recently integrated
JAX, along with
TensorFlow and PyTorch,
in their popular
Transformers library.
And they were able to
pre-train a base-sized BERT
model in less than a day with
just eight cores of v3, which
is the smallest
reservable unit of a pod.
Similarly, our
users at Gridspace,
which provides contact
center automation
tools, such as low-latency
speech analytics,
were able to train both
speech and language
models with an immediate
2x performance improvement.
They were also able to scale
these models on Cloud TPU parts
with no code changes.
These usability and
performance benefits
make it much easier than
ever before to get started
with Cloud TPUs and scale
your machine learning models
on Cloud TPU pods.
Along with this powerful
user experience,
Cloud TPUs also support
all the major machine
learning frameworks, including
TensorFlow, PyTorch, and JAX.
We encourage you to
check out these links
and try out our reference
models and tutorials.
In summary, at Google
Cloud, we believe
that cutting-edge machine
learning infrastructure
should excel at performance,
usability, and scalability.
So we'll continue to invest
in making our systems
more easy to use,
enterprise-class,
and open and pervasive.
Hopefully, with all of these
updates on Cloud GPUs and Cloud
TPUs, our cutting-edge machine
learning infrastructure
is much more accessible and much
more useful to you than ever
before.
Thank you.